قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان وحداتها
احبطت محاولات القوات الاوكرانيه الهجوم
على مناطق في جنوب مقاطعه دوناتس واعلن
المتحدث باسم الوزاره ايجار كوناشنكوف ان
سلاح الجو الروسي دمر مواقع لقياده
العمليات الاوكرانيه في خاركيز بروجيا
ودونيس كما اسقطها مقاتلتين اوكرانيتين من
طراز 29 وصخوري خمسه 25
[موسيقى]
معنى
مراسله الجزيره سلام خضر ومن كراماتوس
مراسلنا عامر لا في مرحبا بكم مبدا معك
سلام الله يعين على اخر المعطيات
الميدانيه
سلمى نبدا من مدينه دانيت كما ذكرت قبل
قليل تعرض منطقه كي اف سي لقصف ارتفع عدد
القتلى بحسب السلطات المحليه الى ثلاثه
قتلى وعدد من الجرحى طبعا القصف على عدد
من احياء مدينه دنيت لا يتوقف وانما يكون
متقطعا الملاحظه خلال الايام الثلاثه
الاخيره هو ارتفاع اعداد الاصابات والقتلى
في صفوف المدنيين نتيجه الاستهداف سواء
المدفعي او الصاروخي جنوب مدينه دانيت لا
تزالوا جبهه محتدمه القتال مستمر بين
الطرفين القوات الروسيه تتحدث عن انها
تصدها
ومحاولات تقدم للجانب الاوكراني ولكن هذا
ما قالته وزاره الدفاع ليس هنا فقط في
جنوب الدميات تتحدث عن مناطق اخرى ايضا
تحدثت عن صدي محاوله هجوم من منطقه
اوجليدار باتجاه ايضا مواقعها وقالت ان
عددا من الجنود الاوكرانيين
استسلموا نتيجه هذه المعارك بحسب ما اعدنا
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع ولكن اللافت
اليوم سلمى في فترات سابقه من هذا اليوم
صباحا قرابه الظهر تقريبا كنا نتحدث عن
اننا رصدنا تحليقا لطائرات او لمقاتلات
روسيه على علو متوسط هنا فوق مدينه دنيتس
وقلنا فلنتظر متى تعلنه وزاره الدفاع
فعليا الدفاع الروسيه وبخلاف الاحاطه
اليوميه اصدرت بيان تحدثت عن انها تكثف
استخدام ما تسميه الطيران التكتيكي
والعملات والعملاتني وتقول ان هذه الطلعات
الجويه تهدف بشكل كبير الى استهداف ما
تصفه مواقع القياده وايضا مرابط المدفعيه
ومواقع اطلاق الصواريخ خاصه التي تستهدف
مدينه سواء الاحياء القريبه من الجبهات
القتال جنوبا او حتى احياء داخل المدينه